auprès du ce tri s'est affaiblie nous
avons vu certains de nos fleurons
industriels et technologiques passer
sous pavillon étranger sans que nous
puissions nous souhaitions réagir
[Musique]
le protectionnisme c'est la guerre c'est
un mensonge c'est le repli
[Musique]
ce
je trouve que en termes de protection de
ce qu'est un outil stratégique de l'état
c'est extrêmement grave
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la france ne peut pas être le seul pays
qui ne fait pas respecter ses intérêts
qu'il faut que la france de se
ridiculiser sur un certain nombre de
dossiers dont celui ci il faut être
extrêmement déterminé ce que ne sont pas
évidemment tout le monde a compris les
autorités françaises qui vont une fois
de plus se faire traîner dans la farine